would you believe that the mosquito who
is responsible for more human deaths
than any other living creature when it
sucks your blood it can transmit
diseases like malaria yellow fever and
sefa lightest and West Nile virus of
course a mosquito takes quite a journey
before it's prepared to make a plasma
withdrawal before stages of its
lifecycle our egg the female lays her
eggs in water she often lays over 200
eggs at a time and the eggs can survive
five years before hatching larvae the
larva feeds on microorganisms in the
water which is why places with plenty of
stagnant water like the Everglades or
last summer's abandoned wading pool in
the backyard are good breeding grounds
then there's pupae which is just a quick
non feeding transitional phase and
finally adult ready to join the billions
of airborne bloodsuckers a female may
live about a hundred days by the way
only females insert their blood siphon
into your skin and drink your life
essence they need a blood meal in order
to produce eggs
males are satisfied with nectar from
flowers now to be fair there are 3,000
mosquito species around the world many
don't bite humans preferring other
species then finally you're more likely
to get bitten if you have smelly feet
mosquitoes like women who are ovulating
and blondes more than brunettes and
biting activity increases five hundred
times during a full moon which does not
help their reputation as creepy
creatures